MAX SALTONSTALL: Welcome to
"BeyondCorp in a Bottle,"
where we explore
journeys into the world
of context-aware access
in zero trust networks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
More and more
companies have shifted
to bring your own
device policies,
allowing employees to
work with the computers
they know and love.
This also reduces the IT spend
per employee, a popular--
if troublesome-- trend.
But as we think about
securing corporate services
and applications,
we need to ask,
how healthy are those devices?
Should I trust them
with my company's data?
No.
No, you should not, because
you don't know what's on them.
You don't know
anything about them.
Let's look at how our friends
at Slager Bank and Trust
tackle this problem using
endpoint verification
and Access Context
Manager on GCP.
First, gather the data.
They used the Google
Admin controls
to install the Endpoint
Verification Chrome
extension on all devices
under active management.
They also told employees
using their own laptops
to install the same extension.
Next, they turned to GCP's
Access Context Manager
to create rules and
policies around trust.
They could define
their own rules
for earning enough trust to
get to internal applications.
To start out, they made rules
based on minimum Chrome OS
version.
That way, nobody with an
out of date Chromebook
would be able to access
their company data.
As they gathered more
device information,
they added rules
based on other factors
to make sure nobody
with an unencrypted disk
could leak information
through a lost device.
In the end, they
settled on access policy
that looked like this--
a low-trust tier for an
up-to-date device and a higher
trust tier for encrypted
and up-to-date devices.
When someone signs in who
doesn't meet the security
criteria, they'll
see this instead.
This step allowed
the teams at Slager
to improve their control
over secure access
to the company's systems
while still preserving
bring your own device policies.
To get more detail, check
out my post linked below
for step-by-step instructions,
and subscribe for more videos
on context-aware access.
When it comes to protecting your
company, keep your data yours.
[MUSIC PLAYING]